do you know the 4th core value of old money?
it's etiquette and manners.
we often overcomplicate etiquette,
but at the end of the day, if you want to understand it,
it's just having common courtesy for others
or those who are viewing you,
interacting with you or are in your presence.
obviously all manners and all etiquette
is gonna require a little bit of practice.
but more importantly,
it's going to require you to have awareness.
now, if you don't believe me,
don't take my word for it,
we have been talking all things old Money
over on Instagram,
over on YouTube, and of course here on TIKTOK.
we've been diving deep on this book all about old money.
I would love if you joined me.